how everybody at Robbie from the wire
Gadget Lab and i'm here at leap motion
testing the leap this is probably the
most impressive interface I've seen well
ever actually it's using infrared
technology little infrared cameras to
read my fingers all of them and it just
not you know just the five fingers I can
put ten fingers I can use a pencil it
can tell the orientation of what you're
holding up in there it's really
impressive and I don't want to leave I
want to stay here and I've already asked
the guys who run this place if they're
aliens and there they won't tell me yes
or no so I'm going to go with yes so the
leap it's it's going to be seventy
dollars it's going to start shipping in
in the winter you can pre-order it now
so we'll have the link in the in the
article color me impressed that's Robbie
I'm from Gadget Lab and expect a full
review when the leap comes out
you